I kind of say that I regret doing three
languages at the same time, but if I had
the discipline, I would focus on one now.
Hi, Steve Kaufman here and, uh, today
I want to talk about my experience
in learning or trying to learn
several languages at the same time.
A subject I've talked about before.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, uh, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
So I've talked about this before, and
this is something that comes up a lot.
People who do learn several languages
at the same time, or would like
to learn several languages at
the same time, is it a good idea?
Not a good idea?
And so forth.
So I have tended to say it's
best to focus on one language.
However, there are advantages to trying to
learn more than one language at one time.
And basically that's sort of the
experiment that I embarked on.
It's gotta be three years ago where
I said, I'm going to learn three
Middle Eastern languages, Turkish,
Arabic, and Persian or Farsi.
Um, and my reason for doing that was,
first of all, the reasons were one:
I didn't want to go...
I know it takes a long time
to learn any one language.
So if I were to focus on Arabic
then for two years, I would
not do any Persian or Turkish.
So, if I were to learn all three
languages, it might take me six
years or more to achieve any kind
of a level in any one of them.
So I said, well, if I go three months on
one and three months on the other, you
know, I kinda maintain all three of them.
I won't move along as quickly,
but I won't forget as much.
And so that's kind of what I've
been doing for the last three years.
Uh, I decided to stop the Turkish because
one of the obstacles for me in Persian and
in Arabic was simply the writing system.
The problem, the difficulty in learning
a writing system is not so much
learning what the different symbols
or characters or letters represent,
it's actually training your brain to
read, uh, and to convert, you know,
Writing into meaning instantly the
way we do in our own writing system.
And it's just an awful lot harder.
Uh, I, I still find it easier to read
in Czech or Polish than in Russian or
Ukrainian, even though I speak Russian,
certainly a lot better than Czech.
Uh, you can't sort of discount the
sort of sense of familiarity with
a script that we grew up with.
And, uh, of course, you know, all of
the Cyrillic script is essentially
parallel to the Latin script.
So it's not that difficult to learn.
Uh, on the other hand, Persian
and Arabic present me...
at least they were difficult for me.
So I said, okay, I'm going to focus
on them and leave the Turkish.
So I've been doing that.
And I would say that really
my progress has suffered.
Uh, I have, uh, a smattering of
certainly Arabic and Persian.
Um, not only that in Arabic, I've
decided to expose myself to Levantine
Arabic and, uh, Egyptian Arabic, which
also introduces a level of confusion.
But, um, and the reason I'm doing that
is that I want to be able to understand
movies from Lebanon, movies from Egypt
and, um, Arabic speaking people, they
speak their own dialect to each other
and they somehow manage to communicate
across different dialects with the
exception of people from North Africa.
So I kind of feel if I'm doing my
Arabic thing, then I should kind of
be familiar with Levantine Arabic and
Egyptian Arabic, and actually the two
Egyptisn and Levantine are closer to each
other than they are to Standard Arabic.
But you still need the Standard Arabic
in order to read and in order to
understand, you know, radio political
podcasts and things of that nature.
So my Arabic is kind of at a standstill.
Uh, Persian I think I'm doing
better at, and I have, it's more
comfortable, easier for me to speak
in Persian when I speak to my tutor.
But there's no question that if
I were to focus on one, I would
be much, much further ahead.
And so then I say to myself, okay, why
don't I just focus on Persian now and
trying to get it up to a decent level?
Uh, but then of course there's always
that, geez, you know, I come across an
interesting something in Levantine Arabic.
Uh, in fact, I bought a book
recently, um, on, uh, Levantine Arabic
grammar and Levantine Arabic verbs.
And it's fun going to
the lead through that.
So it's kind of hard to let
go, but I probably should.
And no sooner have I done that than
I, I was scheduled to have a, uh,
an interview or a conversation.
Uh, a YouTuber who speaks
Japanese and Turkish.
So I said, geez, I'd better
brush up on my Turkish.
So I go back to my Turkish and
after an initial three months
focused on Turkish, I did have an
exit video as I call it in Turkish,
where I actually was able to speak.
I couldn't do that now.
Uh, but then I go back to Turkish,
go back to the mini stories,
go back to a bunch of stuff.
And I realized it was how
much I have forgotten.
And also how many words
there are for me to learn.
So I'm kinda nowhere in Turkish,
uh, not where I would like to be in
Arabic a little closer, where I, to,
where I would like to be in Persian.
And now it turns out that I have
an interview or a discussion
with someone from Korea.
And so I said, you know what?
I should kind of brush up my Korean.
I've spent a lot of time on Korean
over the years on again off again.
And it's really not at a
level that I would like.
I'm sure if I, if, you know, when
I have been in Korea can have sort
of casual conversation with people.
I do have theoretically, a large passive
vocabulary, but in fact, I struggle.
Um, so I've been doing very Korean
plus I'm down here in Palm Springs.
Again, you can see my fake bookshop
behind me and we're at a golf course
and there's a large group of young
Koreans who are, uh, this is sort of like
their golf camp with their instructors.
So I like to go and chat a bit and,
uh, and, uh, watch them, with them
all and see if I been imitate them.
So the Korean is back.
So like, there's just no end.
And so then the question really is, is
it really worthwhile doing all of this?
Why bother?
And so I think the question of whether
you should learn more than one language at
the same time, or even as a polyglot, even
if you're not doing it at the same time,
you are entertaining, you are balancing
like this, this, uh, you know, a juggler
who's got all these balls in the air.
Uh, obviously you can't maintain
them all, you know, you're
catching stuff that's falling down.
You can't maintain them all
at the same at the same time.
Um, so then you, I think it very much
depends on the, the sort of, uh, you know,
what your needs are at any given time.
And I definitely enjoy exploring
languages, even the little
bit of Turkish that I have.
I'm very happy that I, I I've done that.
Uh, I'm happy because I enjoy when
I go back to Turkey and I hear the
sounds of Turkish, uh, when I watch
a series in Turkish I get a bit of a
sense of what they're talking about
or the odd word here and there.
And I'm very happy that
I, that I did that.
I'm very happy that I did what I
did in Korean, even though it's not
quite where I would like it to be.
So I think that the simple answer is,
you know, should you study more than
one language at the same time, or even,
should you study more than one language?
Should you focus on one language
and try to be as good as you
possibly can be in that language?
That's...
Finally, you know, in the
end, that's up to you.
I very much applaud people who want
to become as good as they can be in
language X, but at the same time,
uh, it's such a wonderful thing.
And I think back to that great
gentle giant Moses McCormick who
tragically died at a very young age.
Whose life was spent exploring all
kinds of unconnected languages from
every corner of the world and probably
not achieving, you know, C2 or
anything in any of those languages,
but certainly capable of handling
conversations in a variety of languages.
So it depends what you want to do.
Do you want to explore, or you
want to be a perfectionist?
Uh, but if you want to do
well in the language, then I
certainly think you have to focus.
And, uh, I kinda say that I regret doing
three languages at the same time, but if I
had the discipline, I would focus on one.
Now I would go and focus on Persian
and get it up to a really good level
and then go back in and pick up the
pieces, uh, of my Arabic or, or.
And, uh, I've still got pieces
to pick up in a Korean and
Czech and Greek and Romanian.
So that in a sense,
comes with a territory.
If you're going to be a polyglot and
enjoy exploring languages, you're
never going to be satisfied, uh,
with your level in any of them,
but you're going to enjoy them all.
So just a bit of a ramble,
uh, on the subject of studying
more than online at the same.
Thank you for listening.
I hope you find that useful.
And I think I'll leave you my exit videos
after three months of Persian and three
months of Turkish and, uh, of those two, I
think I've improved in Persian since then.
I haven't improved it in Turkish.
Bye for now.